- [Mark] So Crissy tell me about,
I guess we should start
with your childhood, right?
Let's hear, how'd you like to start?
What were your earliest memories?
- Well, my earliest memories
were when I was four years old
and I lived with my mom and
my dad and my little brother.
And I remember feeling
like our family was like,
it was like a safe place, it was perfect.
And I mean, I didn't really
have anything to compare it to,
but I was happy.
I remember being happy and,
but there is also other
things going on in my life
that kind of, things changed.
My dad, he liked to preach,
even if he didn't have
church, he's still preaching.
So he raised us with the Bible
and teaching us the Bible.
And we went to church and my
mom's singing in the choir.
And so it was kind of
what our life was like
when I was four years old.
But then there was a side
of my dad that was abusive.
He never abused me physically
or my, well, he did actually,
he did it, he did it with my brother,
but also it was confusing
because he preaches
and teaches this one thing
and then he, does that...
- [Mark] Some behaviors that contradict.
- Yes, exactly.
- Who he is.
- Yeah, so and one of the
things he would tell me
is that, I mean, I was
only four years old.
He said, he would say, "If
anybody ever touches you
let me know and I'll kill them.
Nobody's gonna touch my daughter."
And he would go off on this tangent.
And at four years old, I
didn't know what that meant,
but it scared me.
- [Mark] Sure.
- When I was four years
old was also the first time
I was molested by a neighbor.
And I didn't tell anybody because,
thinking that my dad's gonna kill somebody
is terrifying for a kid.
- Yeah.
- It wasn't like a safe place
to go and talk it and talk it out.
So I didn't tell anybody.
After, around the age,
where is it, like 11 ish?
My parents, we moved around
a lot, but we were living
in this house and we moved
in with another person
because he was ill.
So we moved in with him and-
- [Mark] Where did you grow up?
- What?
- Where did you grow up?
- Oh, I grew up in Jacksonville.
- [Mark] Oh, Florida?
- Mm-hmm.
So anyways, so we moved to this new place.
My dad started drinking.
I mean, if he was drinking before age 11
I didn't really know.
He did go out a lot, but during this time
I remember
coming home and he and his friend
were like working on a car outside
and I saw a beer and I
remember it scared me.
Now, I don't know why, but I
just think, "Oh, that's wrong."
And it scared me.
But then,
'cause I started noticing
my dad's behavior
being different and he's being more,
fighting with my mom
more and stuff like that.
And,
I don't know, it just
kind of really scared me.
But also during that time,
he had a lot of friends
that he would bring or
that would come to our home
or we had neighbors that we
would go over their house
and they had a bonfire going.
So all of them drink beer.
So I was exposed to a lot
of drunk men and my dad.
And,
I don't know,
how do I say?
I noticed during that time in my life
that men were looking at me,
these drunk men that were adults
were looking at me in a
different kind of way.
And I guess, because I was getting older
and a lot of times they
would tell me I'm pretty
or, it was just, they were kind of weird.
And so I picked up on that.
They also did it with, did that to my mom,
and my mom was so beautiful
and young and my dad,
his friends would hit on her
and then he would get mad and
he would take it out on her.
So it was very unhealthy relationship.
And also whenever my dad,
they would have a bonfire.
I remember one time in
particular, he was drunk.
He got on the fire, because
he did stuff like that.
He's like, "My daughter is a virgin."
Something like she's, I don't know.
I don't even know exactly what he said,
but he was talking maybe being a virgin.
And he did that quite often.
My mom would always make them shut up
but this particular time, I
don't even think she was around
but it was so embarrassing.
I didn't really understand it.
And at the same time we had,
there was this little boy
that was his, my dad's friend,
his son was molesting me
during this time.
All the time, I would have
to fight them off or kick him
really hard to get away from him.
My brother, my little brother,
he's two years younger than me
he went to do the same thing.
He would fight him off.
But I mean, this kid,
he knew a lot about sex
and his dad was abusive,
very physically abusive 'cause I saw it.
And so I didn't wanna tell on him
because I knew that he would get beat.
So I didn't.
And, but he was just, we
lived there for maybe a year
and that's how long I
had to deal with that.
But then also like in school, like,
I don't know why but these
kids always were drawn to me.
And when things like that
would happen, I freeze.
So I had, even in like
first grade I had a kid
throw me on the ground
and try to have, like,
I don't know what, he
wasn't having sex with me,
but we had our clothes
on, and it was just.
How did kids even know that kind of stuff?
I don't know.
So it kinda grew up with that.
And the secret that I
couldn't really tell anybody,
and I felt like I was
doing something wrong.
I felt dirty.
I felt embarrassed.
I felt into the shame.
I felt angry.
And so that happened
throughout my childhood.
Then in my teen years,
my parents had split up
and my dad took us away from our mom.
And we moved to a different city.
He kind of basically kidnapped us.
And it took a few days, and
then he let us call my mom.
And then they tried to work it out.
And so he would...
- [Mark] So you got, what do you mean
you got kidnapped here.
- Basically, yeah, my dad and
my mom had a really bad fight.
My dad was jealous because my
mom left the Christmas party
with his friend to get
dropped off at our home.
And he went off the deep end.
And this is back when kids
could stay home alone.
So we were sleeping, and
they came home fighting
and it was the scariest fight
I think I've ever heard.
At that point that they
would fight a lot actually,
during this time.
That night my mom finally got,
well, when they would fight she
would take me and my brother
and leave the house
and go to my grandma's.
But this time he threatened
to kill her if she took us.
So she left without us
which was the first
time that ever happened.
She always would protect us.
And then my dad, he gave us
each a trash bag and said,
put whatever you want to take in the back.
And we didn't know where we were going.
But we did that, we threw
it in the back of the truck
and he drove us away to a new city,
basically kind of kidnapping us.
We couldn't call our mom for a few days
but eventually we did.
Biggest dream in life, I didn't
have like a certain career.
I just wanted to get
married and have a baby.
When I was 17 I really started having
like a serious boyfriend.
I thought this was gonna be my husband.
So he got me pregnant.
I didn't care if I didn't
finish high school,
I was gonna, I don't know,
I just had this like,
I guess kind of like a fairy
tale like expectations.
But if he said he wasn't gonna marry me
and I ended up not being
able to have the baby.
I ended up going to the
clinic and having an abortion.
I already had so much trauma in my life
that this was just like the worst thing
that could ever happen.
That pushed me over the edge.
When I started high
school in my senior year
I didn't care about anything.
I was more rebellious than ever.
I was severely depressed.
I had zero drive and I almost
didn't graduate high school.
I just started living with
a couple of roommates.
And then I had a boyfriend,
very unhealthy relationship.
We lived together for a little while
and then we broke up and
I had to move back home.
And then I lived with somebody else,
and then broke up and then
had to move back home again.
And I would go on dating
websites, email people
and try to find somebody
to marry me basically,
'cause I wanted to get married.
That was my biggest dream.
My mission was to find my husband
and I like go to different
states to meet people.
That wasn't a good idea.
I was raped, I was roofied,
I was all kinds of, really bad thing.
I would tell my mom about it.
She was like, "I don't think
that's a good idea, Christina."
"I'm gonna do it anyway."
But what in my heart like what
I really wanted to hear was,
"I love you. And I want you to be safe.
And I don't think it's a good idea."
I wanted to hear that,
but I just heard that
it wasn't a good idea.
So I'm just like, "Nobody cares."
So I was very careless and
all these bad things happen
and I didn't find my husband.
Well, anyway, I liked this
guy and I met him actually
at a bar where he was playing pool.
And we moved in together
and lived together
for about a year.
I got engaged to him, but
there was a problem in that
he wasn't able to express his emotions.
He wasn't able to say, "I love you."
There were some weird things happening
with ex-girlfriends of his
coming to our home and stuff.
So I broke up with him and
then I moved back home again.
I ended up meeting
somebody else right away,
but I didn't move in with him.
He broke up with me.
It was like a rock bottom.
I had a lot of rock bottoms.
So this was like one of
them, I was devastated.
I really liked this guy.
And I don't know why.
I don't know why I really
liked him, but I did.
And so I got back on the internet,
started trying to meet people again.
And I had a really good
job and I made decent money
and I was only going up
because I always felt
I was one of the people in this office
that was up for office manager.
And it is a big office and
a lot of people in there,
and I kind of screwed it up
because I kept getting online.
And then people started
emailing me about doing,
well, I found a modeling website.
And the people who were
posting on it weren't models.
They were just regular people.
I'm not saying they're not attractive
but not like the typical
like magazine fashion models.
And so I was like, "Hmm,
they're getting work.
I wonder if I could try
that and see what happens."
And I just, I didn't think
I would ever have anybody
once hire me but immediately
after I put my portfolio up there
I had people sending me emails to do porn.
And I was,
I don't know, it wasn't flattering to me,
because when I thought
a porn that was like
to me at that time, and I did,
all the guys had lived with
up to that point watched porn
while we lived together.
And I didn't like it.
I didn't like feeling like I
had to compete with anybody
to get loved, to earn
love from the person.
And so I felt like there was a standard
I can never live up to.
So that was really hard for me.
And so when people were
emailing me asking me,
"Did you?" I was like, "No, I'm not gonna,
why would I do that?
I'm like, I'll model in a
bathing suit, but that's it."
But then when this breakup happened,
it's something, I couldn't
get out of bed to go to work.
I almost lost my job.
But I didn't really have,
I didn't really care
about my life anymore.
So yeah,
so I started,
so it took a little while.
I ended up meeting a photographer
that shot Playboy models.
And this was different than porn
because the girls are really beautiful.
They're airbrushed,
they're showing stuff
but they're not like,
not showing everything.
And so I was thinking, "Hmm, I wonder."
He's like, "I want to
submit you for Playboy."
And I was like, "Oh, he
thinks I can do that."
So that was flattering to me.
That made me feel like
I was worth something.
And all these other people
don't see me as anything,
but this person who shoots
these kind of girls,
he wants to shoot me.
And so I gave in.
And so that was my first shoot.
I went, I met him at a hotel.
I was so brave.
I guess I wasn't really
brave, I just didn't care.
And so I was like, well, if
something happens, who cares?
If something happens to me,
I'll be out of this world.
And I was so like, my life was very sad.
So I went there the first
night that we were there
we shot some photos in the room.
He had told me to bring
lingerie, so I brought that.
And so I remember the first shot,
the first shoot that we did, he's like,
"Stand on that side of
the bed, and I want you,"
He told me where to put
my hands and what to do.
And at first it was kind
of, it was really weird.
It was very awkward.
But at first it was really scary.
But then when he said, take your top off,
that was like the scary, scary part.
And I remember feeling,
this isn't a good idea.
But this person traveled
to meet me in this hotel.
I owe it to him to do the shoot.
So I went through with that.
I had certain boundaries, what I would do
and what I wouldn't do.
But then he shot me the next day.
And he talked to me to do any
more than what I wanted to do.
So that happened.
After that shoot I got, I
was not right in my head.
I was just kinda like, what did I just do?
Like, then I saw the pictures
and it was really strange
'cause I never seen myself like that.
And I didn't like it.
And I'm like, "I'm not
gonna ever do that again."
But I ended up doing that again.
In between online dating and
I waited to do these shoots.
I didn't do a lot, but
after maybe my third shoot
with like maybe three
different photographers
I ended up meeting this one
photographer I was shooting with
and they were in LA and they booked me.
And I was shooting in the
mansion, this huge house
with spiral staircase, marble everywhere.
And they have a makeup
person and hair person,
and all these things that I
had never seen before my life.
And they were gonna pay me a lot of money.
And it wasn't gonna be,
it wasn't gonna be showing everything.
It's just gonna be like Playboy's style.
So when I was shooting with them
I ended up not sticking
to my boundaries again.
I had a feeling of obligation.
They're paying me, they flew
me here, I owe it to them.
I think that's kinda like my
attitude throughout my life,
was kind of like, "I owe them."
So the shoot was kind of exciting in a way
until you had to start taking off clothes.
And then I would, I learned
growing up being molested
that you can mentally just check out.
So I would check out,
I would just associate,
it was if I'm thinking of
myself as being a piece of art
and I'm looking down on myself
to see how the camera is seeing me
and to make eye contact with the camera.
Like, it is weird, but I wasn't me.
I was somebody else.
And that's the only way I could do it.
But then I got paid,
but most of the time the
money, that was like secondary
what I really wanted
was acceptance and love.
And just to know that
I mattered to somebody
in some, any kind of way.
And that's what being
in the industry gave me.
So I was shooting with these people.
This man showed up that they
knew, and he was a manager.
He managed different girls.
His girls were, did the softer stuff
that wasn't like hardcore porn.
And they were pretty.
And one of them only did
like Playboy style things
and he wanted to represent me.
And I was kind of
flattered because the girls
he shot were really pretty.
So I ended up working with him.
And I lost my job because I
kept getting on the internet.
And there were times where
I couldn't show up to work
because of, I was either
doing a photo shoot,
or I was depressed, or I was a real mess.
So I ended up losing my job
and then I started my own website.
And I was dating a guy,
we were living together.
'Cause I a guy that I
dated, we moved in together,
because I don't know, I don't know why.
I just wanted to get
married and have a baby.
So we lived together for about a year.
And when, he, okay, so this person,
he had porn magazines
and they were of women
with breasts, like huge, like
bigger than their head each.
It was weird, well, to me
it was weird. I don't know.
It was a fetish pretty much.
It wasn't just normal.
They were like, I can't
even, I won't go into that.
I try not to go into it.
But he had these magazines,
and I didn't look like that at all.
So yeah.
So it still was kind of weird to me.
I didn't like it,
even though I was doing my
own website and shooting,
But this was gonna be husband.
Like he shouldn't be looking at, you know.
If he's flattered that I'm doing it,
like I didn't want him
looking at other women.
I just couldn't give into that.
That was hard for me.
But we ended up having a really bad fight
and he started packing
my stuff up in my car.
And I was like, "If you keep
putting my stuff in my car
I'm gonna leave and I'm
never gonna come back."
And I was still living in Jacksonville
So he wouldn't stop packing on my car.
So I had to follow through.
So I got my car and I just
started, I just drove.
I didn't know, I didn't have a map or,
I mean, I had a paper map,
but I didn't have like a
cell phone with a map on it
to tell me where I'm going.
So I just got on the
road and started driving.
And then I realized,
"Oh, I'm in Tampa. I know
somebody who lives there."
I knew two people who lived
there and I was tired.
So I called one of them.
I went and stayed at his house.
It was another, it was a guy
who was like a model or whatever.
So stayed with him, I
didn't really like him.
He got on my nerves.
So I called the photographer
that lived out there
that has shot me before
and told him I was there.
And I don't remember how
exactly it went down.
But,
I ended up moving in with him right away.
Like I didn't have to stay
by myself and I didn't ever
wanna be by myself.
That was too scary for me.
So I move with him and with him.
He was a webmaster. He shot his ex-wife.
She had her website, he had shot me,
and then he's took over my website.
He took it to the next level.
And yeah, I was severely
depressed in that relationship.
I really never really left my bedroom
unless I needed to eat.
And he was okay, just letting
me, don't do anything.
But he would shoot me and
he would push my boundaries
and he got doing things I,
going even further with things.
And it was a weird relationship.
He was the same age as my mom.
And he's a lot older than me
and we never told each other
that we loved each other,
but we were a couple.
It was very strange.
But after about a year, a year and a half
of living with him, I ended up,
well, he broke up with me.
I wasn't shooting a lot of
stuff except for my website.
'Cause that was my main income.
So because my website was good
and I made a lot of money,
that meant that I didn't
have to shoot every week,
or two weeks or whatever.
I could just do what I wanted to do.
But it wasn't making a lot of money.
So I wasn't always able to,
well, I did pay my rent,
but there was, some times
where it was really hard
to pay my rent.
And one time I had to do a contest.
I heard about it on the radio
and it was like hot legs contest.
And if you knew me, this is
not something I would do.
It was really dumb.
And it was like, I won,
but it was 500 bucks,
that was my rent.
And it was so gross.
It was weird.
I don't even know what I did.
But, so I got to pay my rent that time.
And I got back on the dating websites.
And then I ended up meeting
somebody that I didn't like.
Well, I missed for, I met a
friend and then I met him.
I was supposed to date his friend,
but they, he took me to
introduce me to his friend
and they end up raping me.
And I went back to my ex-boyfriend,
told him what happened.
He's like, "Do you think
that he would wanna shoot
for my website?"
Like shoot you two together.
And I was like, "Did he just hear me?
Like I'm crying.
They raped and I'm devastated."
And he's asking me that.
And I'm just, I felt so alone and unloved
and I didn't have
relationship with my family
at all, nothing.
So I was like, I'm never gonna hang out
with those guys again.
And maybe three weeks went by
and I'm by myself and meeting guys,
they're coming to my apartment.
And I'm feeling obligated to be with them
even if I didn't like them
because they took the time.
I don't know, it's just
this weird thing that I had.
And I guess, kind of being with
somebody in any kind of way
was better than being by myself.
'Cause that was the worst thing to me.
I didn't have friends or anybody.
So I'm...
- [Mark] You had a long
string of boyfriends tough.
- Yes, I have had lots of
boyfriends or hookups or whatever,
all of it.
I thought that in order
to get a boyfriend,
you have to be this certain kind of girl
and you have to definitely
have sex with them
or they're not gonna move you in.
Like you have to get
something, like the men,
what do they like?
They want a feminine
girl who's hot and sexy
and like a porn girl and all these things.
So I was, I never felt
like I was good enough.
Like I always needed to change something
because this person is into this
or sexually or looks wise
or stuff like that.
And yeah, so I didn't want to see that,
I didn't want to see the
guy I went on the date with,
I didn't want to see the guy
that he introduced me to,
but there was one night in particular
I was alone and I was sad.
And I was depressed
and I was wanting to kill myself.
And they contacted me, well, the one
that I went on the date with
contacted me to hang out at some club
and it was just like, okay, whatever,
like is better than being by myself.
I maybe this isn't, they raped me,
but I've been raped before, so who cares?
So this is so weird to
even hear myself saying,
because it's so different now
that I was, it was very sad.
So we hung out that night and I ended up
hanging out with the friend,
the friend, the guy's friend.
And yeah, so after that
I moved in with him.
And the guy who raped
me, I moved in with him.
He took over my porn career,
and he started getting me
contracts with other people.
He started shooting photos of
me and other people together.
He started like taking
over my whole business.
And we were together for
three and a half years.
At the time I was in the industry.
And a lot of people didn't
know that he was abusive.
He was physically
abusive, verbally abusive.
He was terrifying to me.
And I was very isolated.
So we ended up moving from
Florida together to California.
And,
it was a bad relationship.
There was drugs.
I tried almost every drug there is.
Thank God I didn't get addicted.
That's just like a miracle.
But he was definitely addicted
to everything and anything.
It didn't matter if it was sex or drugs
or other women, he cheated on
me, but I didn't have proof.
It was one of those things
where they make you feel crazy.
But I knew in my heart
that I can prove it.
He lived a crazy lifestyle
that was outside of our relationship.
He had a working relationship
with somebody who,
I don't know if I wanna go into all that,
but they paid him for
what he did with them.
And it was with men and
paid him a lot of money.
He got a new car.
He, but he was never home.
His roommate, I lived with him in our home
and he would come home sometimes.
But most times he was
out making his money.
And he had a manager too,
aside from this one person.
He had a regular talent manager
and he had worked in the porn
industry before I ever did.
But he was out of it and he was just doing
his escorting stuff.
So and, I was so naive to think
that he wasn't actually having sex.
And he's not actually gonna shoot a movie.
I really didn't have proof of these things
until we broke up.
And then I saw all.
He was doing movies. He was
doing all kinds of stuff.
So three and a half years,
abuse, drugs,
all the bad things,
doing porn,
feeling empty,
feeling afraid to be by myself.
That is better to be abused
and to be alone.
And at least I could just go another room
and do some drugs and tune out everything.
And when he was high, he was not,
he was actually kinda nice or funny.
But when he wasn't, oh my Gosh,
he was scary.
He was huge guy with big
chest, big and muscles.
And he could easily
take me down and he did.
And he would say
that he was always gonna
put me six feet under.
That was like his phrase
that he would use for me.
And, okay so I never thought
I would be in a relationship
with somebody that was
so much like my dad.
And I said that would never happen,
but I feel like my life
had broke me down so much,
all of these things that
I had zero self worth.
And there was a part of me
that wanted him to kill me.
And that's,
that's terrible to say, but it's true.
Yeah, so we broke up
and then I went back to online dating.
I knew what my problem
was, like, didn't learn.
I never learned.
And then I ended up
meeting a really nice guy.
So my last year of being
in the porn industry,
I met this guy and he was nice.
He had his son, so it was
like I would be an instant mom
and didn't have to have it.
I didn't have to birth that child.
I would be a mom and a wife.
And he was, he's not into the
porn industry or anything.
He was a mainstream actor.
So during this time, like
we spent 24/7 together,
all the time.
Every day, all day, we had our routine.
We would go and hike, then
we would eat breakfast.
Then we would go home.
And everything was, every day.
We didn't really spend any time apart.
And we were together
for a year and a half.
So the end of our relationship,
he went on a little trip
and he was being filmed,
because he is an actor, he is being filmed
for a mainstream show, not a porn thing.
And before he left, I
felt really insecure.
And I said, cause he
didn't, he wasn't taking me.
And I said, "Please, don't
go to any strip clubs."
And I don't know.
I just felt like if he's
gonna get away from me,
he's gonna do something bad.
So I said that to him, he's
like, "Oh, I wouldn't do that."
So after he got out there, he called me
the one night really, really, really late.
And it was like after 2:00 AM.
And I asked him where he was,
he was slurring, he was drunk.
And he said, "Oh, I'm at P. F. Chang's."
I'm like, "It's too late
to be at P. F. Chang's,
that's not where you're at, I hear music."
And he was drunk, so he
tried to convince me.
And then I think it, he
swore to me that he wasn't
at a strip club and I
knew, I just knew it.
I just knew it that day, that
night I could barely sleep.
The next day he called me
in and I got him to admit
that that's where he went.
And that's where they did.
He went to the strip club
and I was devastated.
I was like, I thought this
guy, he's the nice guy,
he wasn't abusing me.
But he went to a strip club.
He had time on his own
and that's what he did.
And I was at the peak of my porn career,
if you wanna call it that.
I was making a lot of
money, a lot of money.
I was just at the top
and I still wasn't enough.
And that's what was really
hard for me to grasp.
Is that.
At this point I would,
everything on me was fake,
my hair extensions, which
there's nothing wrong with that.
But that was part of my identity.
I had to have the hair,
I had to have the nails,
I had to have the tan.
I had to have all of these things.
These were who I was.
That was my identity.
Everything was wrapped around people
wanting to pay me to do stuff or to,
like pay me to shoot for their
magazine or this, or that.
And that was giving me my work,
And, or the people desired
me, or that I had fans
that would email me and say that somehow
I make their life more complete.
Like all of these things
where my identity and so,
I worked so hard to be in
shape, like all of these things.
And then my boyfriend, who
I thought I was gonna marry,
who was the good guy,
went to a strip club.
And it sounds so silly
because I'm doing porn,
but my expectations were different.
And I felt like I knew that
the man that I was gonna marry
was not gonna do that.
He's not even gonna be tempted to that.
He's gonna be focused on me and only me.
And I'm gonna be,
I don't know, I'm gonna be loved.
So him going into the club,
I knew that he didn't really love me.
He admitted that he lied
to me and I was devastated.
I hung up the phone and I cried,
I like sat on the floor in my kitchen.
I'm like, "God, if you're real,"
because I grew up believing
in God, but where was he?
"If you're real, I need to know it.
And I need a sign."
Like, "I've lost all hope.
Everything I know about love
is twisted and perverted.
And I don't even know if
I believe in it anymore?"
So I was like, "God just
please give me a sign,
give me a sign."
And so, the next day, that night
I made a list of pros and cons.
'Cause I'm like, I'm not thinking clearly.
And I never really did that before.
So I'm like, why should I
stay? And why should I leave?
Make this list, the leave
list was a lot longer.
And that gave me some clarity.
I flew out to where he was
filming, to be with him.
And when I got there, I
didn't love him anymore.
It was like, those feelings were gone.
I didn't even like him anymore.
And so anyway, I went out
there and he was introducing me
to people that were working on the film
or that were in the movie,
and I met this guy named,
this guy, I met this guy
and he was really, I mean,
everybody on set was nice.
But when my boyfriend was shooting,
he got me to have a conversation with him.
And he asked me what I did for a living.
And I said, "Oh, I'm a model."
Like, "What kind of modeling do you do?"
I'm like, "The car
magazines, like the model
that's what I do."
And he didn't believe me.
He kept asking me more
questions to get me to admit it.
And so finally I was just like,
"I do adult stuff, like porn."
And he was like, "Yeah,
I already knew that.
Your boyfriend is here,
he's been showing people your photos."
And in our personal life, we
didn't have a lot of friends,
but we didn't go around saying,
introducing me or talking
about me doing porn.
I felt really uncomfortable
that everybody I just talked to
knew, they know what I look like that way.
And I felt really exposed,
like really exposed.
And then he said, he asked me,
"Let me ask you some, Crissy,
do you believe in God?"
And I was like, "Okay,
I asked God for a sign."
Nobody's talked to me about God
in a really, really long time.
So I knew that God was
sending him as a sign.
And I said, "Yes, I do."
And he said, "Well, you don't have
to live this kind of lifestyle.
You can be free, you can break
free and have a new life.
And do you believe that?"
And I'm like, "I don't know.
I don't know what I believe."
But there was this hope,
because God sent me a sign.
And then he was like,
"Do you wanna go outside
and pray with me?"
And so I prayed.
And at that time I made a decision
that I was never gonna go
back to that boyfriend.
And then I was gonna leave
and I was gonna quit the industry.
It only took that one
person who was brave.
And I say, it's brave because everybody
that found out about it on set,
were trying to jump him
throughout the rest of the film.
He was very bold and brave.
And he reached out to me
and that's all it took.
And they thought I was gonna
leave my boyfriend for him.
But that wasn't, that was
not what it was happening.
So that night, my
boyfriend he was working,
he came into our hotel and he's like,
so, we're getting ready for bed.
I'm like, "I can't sleep with you."
And he's like, why?
And I'm like, because I
just like made a decision
to change my life.
I can't be in bed with you.
And he laughed.
And he was like like
if you're leaving porn
how are you gonna make a living?
Like, how are you gonna pay your rent?
I'm like, "I don't know.
I don't know, but I know
that God sent me a sign,
that he's gonna take care of me."
So, moved back home.
He was still working at the film,
moved all my stuff out
before he even got there.
My friend, Chris introduced
me to people in LA
that helped me move my stuff.
And these guys were like total gentlemen.
So nice and so kind.
I moved into my own apartment.
I was gone before he ever came home
and I never saw him again.
And then the life changed.
Now I'm not taking any money from porn.
They're still making
money off me indefinitely
for all the model releases that I signed.
I have no control over any
of it, even my website.
So I tell the people who
were running my website,
'cause that was my main
income that, that I'm leaving.
Well, I told my fans first, I was leaving.
And then they found out from
me exposing it to the fans
that I was leaving and
talked to my webmaster.
And he said, "Crissy, if
you would have told me
that you were leaving the
industry to have a family,
I may have let you out of your contract,
but I'm not gonna do that.
But for a fantasy like God."
And I was just like,
"Oh my gosh, like how?"
I couldn't understand it.
Like, because for me, my faith was all,
for me my faith was strong.
And, like from my childhood
to that point it connected.
And I felt like God that loved me.
And I couldn't understand.
I couldn't understand it.
So anyway, so I said, he's like,
"Were you missing your check?"
I'm like, "I don't want the check."
So from that point on, I
never got another check
from my website, which was my main income.
I went from making at
least $15,000 a month
to making nothing.
And I didn't know what was gonna happen,
and a lot of times, people are like,
"What are you gonna do?"
have something in place
for when you do leave.
I didn't have anything.
And I knew that it was okay.
And I knew, I felt like,
I always told me that
he was gonna take care of me.
And to give everything up.
This is what he told me.
It might not be the same for everybody,
but he told me to give everything up
and take a stand and be bold.
And let me show you how much I love you
and how I'm gonna take care of you.
And so, through that process
of losing everything,
gaining weight, like all these things,
I couldn't pay for my hair,
or my tan, or my nails,
and my whole identity was stripped.
And now I'm me, me with short hair,
and I don't know, just
not the fantasy anymore.
And I had to figure out who I really was
without all of those things.
And I didn't know, it was scary.
I had anxiety, I had
depression, I have PTSD.
I was not well, but I had hope.
And like, it's crazy.
All of the unknowns,
God was showing me.
Like, I didn't have my rent,
he would put somebody in my life randomly,
like, I'm gonna pay your rent.
I didn't have food.
People who'll give me food.
And I wasn't profiting at all.
I was barely getting by,
but each little thing was like,
God's giving me a hug.
It was like, "I'm gonna take care of it.
I'm gonna take care of you."
And I knew that it was all him.
It knew it because it
was almost miraculous
like how things happened.
And yeah, so, from just
that moment of that guy
talking to me everything changed.
- [Mark] How many years ago was that?
Let's see, that happened in 2006.
- [Mark] Okay.
- So it's been a long
time, what like 14 years?
- 13 years.
- [Mark] 14?
- So I spent a really long time
and so much has happened
from that moment and to now.
And now I've been married for six years.
I found my husband who has
not even looked at my porn
and is not interested.
He has proved to me that I could trust him
because he had his own story.
He was alone for 10 years without dating
or being with a woman.
And so I'm like, this is
the kind of guy I can trust.
And I still trust him.
And we have a very good
relationship, very good marriage.
My PTSD was really bad
before we got married.
At some point it disappeared.
I don't even know how.
I don't get jealous. I'm not insecure.
Just everything is different.
This is different.
And I just knew,
I just, I knew from the
moment we started talking
that he was gonna be my husband,
just 'cause he treated me so different
than anybody ever had, with respect.
He wouldn't when we met,
we met kind of online,
not like a dating website.
We have a mutual, like real life friend.
And when we met in person, he was still,
what's the word,
walking in the straight and narrow,
like, I would try to like
link my arm through his,
just like as we're walking
through this little garden
he would be like,
"Crissy, stop touching me.
You can't do that. We're just friends."
And then my feelings will get hurt.
And if I feel like, but
that's just showing me
he's gonna be my husband,
'cause God told me that the
guy who's gonna marry me,
he's gonna have a cool last name,
that he's gonna not be tempted.
I mean, he'll be tempted, he's
not gonna follow it through.
And all these things that God told me
that ended up happening.
And so we were friends for a whole year.
I went on, I
fast for men.
I wasn't dating or hanging
out with men for a year,
but I talked to him on the
phone, and he was the only one.
- [Mark] So you were living
in LA, and he was where?
- He was in Houston.
- In Houston?
- Mm-hmm, but the whole
year before we met,
I was on a fast, I stopped talking.
I had lots of guy friends,
lots that I wasn't trying to date.
Because it's like, I'm a Christian
and the Young Adult Christian community
hanging out in groups and stuff like that.
And so I met a lot of friends,
but I stopped hanging
out with any of them,
even if there was no romantic thing,
and just start like really focusing
on my relationship with God.
And then that's, when I started
talking to him on the phone,
I decided to go my fast.
But God told me that he
could stay in my life
because he's in Houston and
he's doing Bible studies with me
over the phone.
So he's bringing me closer to
God, he's not pulling me away.
So yeah, a whole year went by,
then we met in person in December,
and then he wasn't
interested in dating me.
He wasn't the whole time.
He knew that I wasn't dateable.
But so I had a speaking
engagement planned in Houston
on Valentine's day.
So we met December, I didn't
even know about the thing,
and I got it with email,
and I had planned it a year ahead of time.
And they were like, so
here's your information
for the shoot on Valentine's day?
I'm like, okay.
And then I realized it was in
Houston on Valentine's day.
And it was like, this is so funny.
My future has been, is there.
So that day he came to
my speaking engagement,
and it was at a college and
I had my little sticker,
like, it's just something
about waiting to have sex,
to be married, had it on my shirt.
And we went to his house
and then he asked me
to be his Valentine after
my speaking engagement.
And yeah, that's from there,
we just dated a little bit.
And then we got married.
- [Mark] That's great.
- And I moved to Houston to
be with him and his family.
And his family is amazing.
They really are amazing.
- [Mark] So what do you
think helped ground you?
I mean, it was just
the realization that...
- Helped ground me?
I think it was my faith.
And I think that my
relationship with my husband
proved to me that I could trust men
because he was so rigid.
- [Mark] Well, you had such a string
of terrible relationships.
- But he was so rigid,
that if I would send him a
picture of me being sexy,
he would get mad at me.
Like he was so opposite of everybody else.
And I kinda knew in my heart,
like that's the kind
of guy I'm gonna marry.
And it just, that's how it worked out.
I ended up being with the
guy that I could trust.
Because of his rigidness.
- [Mark] But I also think you were ready
for something more substantial than...
- Yeah, I was learning about
how relationships really work,
how they they're supposed to work.
'cause everything I knew growing up...
- [Mark] So you met him
at roughly what age?
- I was,
how old was I?
35 or 36?
- [Mark] Yeah, so yeah.
You were mature, more mature than you were
when you were in your twenties
and desperate for some connection.
- Yeah, I was a lot more mature
and I have been taking like
little classes and I started
going to church a lot
and learning like the model of marriage
and how it works together.
And men want respect, women want love,
just the model of
relationship that's healthy
and all that kind of stuff.
So I learned a lot and thankfully
he had been out of his own pattern of life
for 10 years and he had
been working on himself.
So by the time I met
him, he was in a place
that he could kind of lead
me and lead me spiritually
and grow together as
Christians believers together.
And I trusted him.
I never trusted anybody in my whole life,
and I trust him.
And that's kind of what grounded me.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- It's just, had like finally
not having to be somebody else
and being seen for who I was
and being accepted and loved for it.
That was, yeah, that was the healing,
that healed me.
The PTSD went away.
So never thought that would happen.
It was so bad, but yeah,
I think marriage healed me.
I think marriage gave
me a lot of freedom too.
I didn't have to always wear a mask.
I didn't have to always have my makeup on.
- [Mark] But marriage
to the right person too.
- The what?
- [Mark] But marriage to the right person.
- Yes, to the right.
- 'Cause you probably could
have been married five times.
- I could have been married-
- 15 times.
And they all would have
ended up in train wrecks.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm really glad
that I didn't get married sooner,
'cause it would've been terrible.
I probably would have
had so many husbands.
- [Mark] Or if you had
kids with those husbands
it would have been terrible.
- Yeah, and my abusive ex-boyfriend,
he got me pregnant all the time.
And then he would take
me to get an abortion.
I could have had several kids
and that's makes me really sad.
I don't like to think about it.
- [Mark] Well, what would you say
to young women who are
going through similar?
Not necessarily so extreme,
who are not so extremely off course,
but just who are struggling
with relationships,
struggling with similar things,
what would you say to them?
- I mean, just, I would say,
I would just want to tell them that
they are worthy of love,
that they matter,
that just to hold on,
wait, work on yourself,
don't lose hope and that one day
the right person's gonna come along.
But you have to be the person,
you have to work on yourself
so you have to be the person
that would attract the
kind of man that you want.
Like, what is this what you want,
what kind of woman is he
gonna be attracted to?
And that's what I had to do.
That's why I had to
really focus on growing
and being a good, not a good person,
but just work on myself.
- [Mark] Right, I think you were,
before that point, you were
attracting guys left and right.
But they were the wrong kind of guys.
- And I knew that, like,
I want to be with a guy
who is a leader, that can
lead our relationship.
Not that he's like over me,
it's more like we work together,
but he's stable.
- [Mark] Yeah, but I think a lot of women
can attract a lot of guys
if they look a certain way,
if they act a certain way,
if they behave a certain way,
but you're attracting
the wrong kind of guy.
- Yeah, yeah.
And my standards for men were very low.
- [Mark] Yeah, right.
So I think part of it is
having high standards,
knowing the difference between
guys that are worthless
and guys that are worthwhile,
and being patient and working
on yourself to get there.
- [Crissy] Work on yourself, be the woman
that's gonna attract the
kind of guy that you want.
And it's not easy.
- [Mark] No, having high standards
is a tall order sometimes.
- Yeah, so...
- [Mark] Excellent. Thank
you for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] I'm glad it
worked out so beautifully.
- Thanks.
- Great job.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, Chris.